hi i'm jess hey i'm austin hi i'm floyd
norman
veteran disney artist and storyteller i
worked on
great films like sleeping beauty 101
dalmatians sort in a stone
and walt's final film the jungle book
and that ties into our task today
because
from walt disney's the jungle book we
are going to be drawing
little mowgli and car the python
oh man that's gonna be cool
i'm scared
[Music]
floyd speaking of what we're drawing
today do you have like a favorite
sequence from the jungle book that you
worked on oh yeah yeah uh
i i would say hands down my favorite
sequence uh because uh
i i guess because i was so involved in
it was was the wonderful uh
the second meeting uh of mowgli and carl
well walt wanted a song and robert and
richard sherman
wrote a song called trust in me uh
that we took that song and vance and i
my partner vance gary
we storyboarded the the sequence we had
already
we'd already made one pass but once we
had a song
at the suggestion of walt disney we
re-boarded the sequence
and it's mowgli as he sort of wanders
around
half days half asleep and the coils of
the snake
and beautifully animated by frank thomas
i have to add that
frank one of the nine old men did just a
masterful job of bringing my drawings
to life on screen and just making that
sequence sparkle
yeah i've got a question for you guys uh
because uh
sure you're younger and just coming into
this
into this amazing business did you guys
animate on paper did you do
traditional hand-drawn animation less
for
full animation and more for design for
animation but in college
that's how we learned to animate was
traditionally yeah yeah the basics the
the
basics the bouncing ball squash and
stretch
you you you got a sense of uh weight
and volume these traditional animation
principles
still come in handy even after you make
the move to digital
it's good to come from that you know
that basic solid foundation
like what's the secret to drawing a good
mowglian car mr floyd
well you know mowgli
python uh were animated by
the top disney animators and milk called
in particular we would get
milk calls drawings his sketches his
rough sketches not always
final sketches but his very rough
drawings
and we would study his technique that's
how you got to be better that's how you
became a better artist you saw the best
work and you emulated that so how do you
do a good
mowgli drawing how do you do a good
drawing of car the snake
study the work of those who are better
than you are yeah
i draw with crayola i draw crayola so
i'm just
i'm
hey jess austin how are your drawings
coming
[Music]
i think it's actually looking okay how's
your drawing coming
floyd uh my my only challenge is to as i
often tell my students i try to draw him
on model
because when a disney character is drawn
off model
oh boy that's regarded as a sin
[Music]
you know i started out in the 1950s
by the time i got to the early 70s and i
was animating on a disney feature film
i was beginning to feel like maybe i
know a little bit about animation now
and i was animating robin hood
and this was in around yeah the early
70s we were doing robin hood
and i was animating the fox and it was
fun i was enjoying myself and i was
having a great time
but you know it takes a while to build
that kind of confidence and you have to
do a lot of bad stuff
before you can start to do a lot of good
stuff would you say that was your
favorite film
actually it was one of the films that i
liked the least at disney
well because walt disney owned the
studio after all
it was his studio he could walk into
your room
at any moment unannounced and walt would
do that
people don't you know big bosses and
executives don't do that today they
usually you know when they're coming
there's been
announcements and preparations but walt
disney could simply
one day just wander into your office
and you look around and there's the boss
standing in your office oh my goodness
so
you feel like what you want to do is
just fall off your chair and hide under
your desk
but you can't you can't can't do that
he's already seen you
but that's okay he was he was a good guy
i i don't mean to say
that walt could be intimidating but he
wasn't a bad guy you know he was
he didn't treat people poorly he was he
was very generous very gracious and
i never had any problems with the boss
that's awesome
hey guys how are you finishing your
drawings
uh i'm making it up so
i'm just like hey so i should probably
draw a background oh wait i don't know
how to draw those anyway time to make it
up so like
i'm drawing some i think what are leaves
and
uh trees and bushes and uh
it's fine uh we'll just look at that
yeah you don't necessarily have to draw
a background
i mean you can just sometimes just throw
in a splash of color
yeah it's really not much of a
background i say background to be nice
to myself it's literally just like
blotches of color and i'm like yeah this
is fine
i don't know what i'm nothing wrong with
a good blotch
we'll see you could be you could be the
judge of that
[Music]
[Applause]
oh wow oh my god whoa
they're so cute
jeez floyd yours is so cute you gave it
like a little blush
there's like no comparison it's just
it's a hundred percent
it's a hundred percent mowgli the mowgli
up in the tree at night
it's really interesting but you know
that was one of the
some of the first stuff animated uh
on the jungle book was that sequence of
mowgli
up in the tree at night and car you know
sneaking around
and then this is nice uh with the uh
the jungle background and car
really nice i love your poses austin
it's so
cute i am very impressed these are
these are really nice oh thank you
yeah you guys you put me to shame oh no
don't say that
i'm gonna go scream oh my gosh
upstaged by the kids
100 inspired by the master so hey
i will give you the walt disney
compliment
you know and walt was not lavish handing
out compliments
but he if he liked what you did he would
say two words
that'll work
and that that was high praise from walt
disney
that'll work i'm having a crazy i think
i can i feel crisis right now
it's just like austin's just fangirling
over here
i am it's a lot i'm trying to keep it
together i'm just like okay no it's cool
like be cool and i'm like losing it
to check out these drawings and more
just like them check us out on instagram
draw off show
[Music]
you